retiring early 31 like that is very
young you could have kept going for a
few more years everybody keeps asking
like why did you retire and the main
reason I remember I was talking to
Michael Johnson and I was like why did
you retire at the top EA game and he
said I'd done everything I want to do it
I had no motivation I mean and when I
got to after the Olympics that's exactly
how I felt because my main aim was to
win three Olympics that's what I wanted
to do set the bar high and after that my
motivation kind of just went so for me
it's if you have no motivation to do
anything it doesn't make any sense
because you're not gonna put your 100%
into it and it seems inconceivable now
but presumably someone at some point
will beat your World Records okay you
can see into the future you think they
won't be so we get to the beach and it's
supposed to be a hundred meters it's
supposed to run hundred meters it's
taken so they were like oh we're gonna
give Kevin thirty meters you know I mean
what's gonna be a hundred meters all
right cool probably I'm a chance you
know I mean it's understand so it's
harder to run on Sun you know
oh no they go alright we're gonna take
it down to 80 but we're still gonna give
Kevin art 30 meters that makes
absolutely no 20 meters that no 30 up it
was embarrassing I was tells the story
that he was not given the 30 meters
[Music]
you